inflation numbers 8.5 percent
what is your general thoughts takes on
on the numbers that we're seeing today
i mean uh 8.5 seems pretty cheap you
know if we're comparing it to miami and
25 drinks in the club i mean come on
so i saw you guys down there that was a
fun time um i mean yeah two waters were
twenty dollars i got two waters these
little fiji things that live two of them
twenty dollars ten dollars each i was
like you're out of your damn mind but
then i bought two more
yeah that's that's how they get you i
mean
i think honestly cpi is understating
that you guys have been saying that for
a while i've been saying that for a
while these are the government
statistics but
still i mean it's accelerating um a lot
of people the same people that have been
calling for a you know a top in the you
know accelerating inflation month over
month numbers uh this time around have
been saying that the last six months or
so it'll be interesting to see if we get
somewhat of a kind of a crush of demand
as some of these things continue to soar
like energy um obviously some stuff like
food is the you know demand is inelastic
uh and people just need it to survive
so you're seeing a lot of really kind of
crazy stuff happen with uh say wheat and
agriculture around the world um that's
really interesting to keep an eye on but
i mean in terms of just real yields and
deeply negative state
of basically every every yield in the
entire global bond market that's
accelerating and that's that's the
biggest story in finance today
and do you what percentage of this do
you think if any has to do with what's
happening in russia and ukraine when it
comes to an inflation perspective right
we've seen the white house has said that
a lot of this has to do with russia and
putin and all of the the
uh sanctions and whatnot that have been
placed on him do you think that we're
seeing that in the data yet or do you
think that's to come in the following
months
yeah i mean it's definitely a role but i
think just to to call it putin's price
hike and completely ignore the fact that
you had politically enforced lockdowns
uh of the global economy printed a bunch
of money destroyed supply chains and
then said okay yeah like you know this
inflation's putin's fault uh it's it's
you know somewhat gaslighting and
straight propaganda and anyone that kind
of believes that is is uh
i don't even i don't even know what uh
what to say there
you're searching for the name i can see
your your head spinning and the steam
coming out of it uh but we get what
you're trying to say so you sent us a
bunch of charts which we appreciate so
let's maybe start with uh the 10-year
versus the 10-year treasury yield uh
year-over-year versus uscpi what are you
seeing there
yeah so uh put out a tweet about like an
hour ago and said this is the most
important chart in finance kind of what
i'm referring to when talking about the
state of real yields uh us treasury
markets basically that risk-free rate
for the global economy um and uh it's
essentially what every asset in the
world is valued off of um the story uh
of 2022 has been in the bond market
specifically especially on the short end
has been just the drastic rise in yields
due to this inflation uh inflationary
environment right every fixed income
holder realizes uh that they're you know
they're sitting in contracts guaranteed
to lose money so they sell it off
the value of those bonds goes down uh
the yields go up what you're seeing in
credit markets and really every single
uh like equity is everything else every
asset market is is basically duration uh
which is uh basically how these these
assets are priced right you can think of
duration as the lower yields are the
lower that discount rate is um the the
more that these assets will be
priced off of like high multiples so
when those yields rise
um it's basically that duration of the
asset goes down and the value of it goes
down as well so that's what we're seeing
and that's basically why you're seeing
every single asset kind of trade in
tandem bitcoin and the nasdaq everything
else we have graphics of that uh because
it's all about the usd denominator at
the moment uh this is basically you know
reflecting the liquidity tied
so as that chart starts to compress at
some point right if they raise interest
rates and inflation starts to fall on a
year-over-year level what impact does
that have on on the market from
whether you want to talk about risk
assets or whatever just generally what
impact does that have
yeah i think i mean the story is even if
it somewhat compresses i really think
this the story is that the
you know the 40-year real yield bond
bull market
uh is basically was you know shot behind
the shed in 2020 2021 maybe 2022. if you
want to call it that but i really think
it happened post covid
where you could just sit in in
treasuries you could sit in bonds and
you could basically just ride this this
wave of ever ever lower yields and a lot
of things
demographics debt and globalization let
these kind of inflation levels
never never see anything you know higher
than four or five percent since the 80s
and so this was just basically a very
very good environment for financial
assets
and for you know specifically because of
our world reserve currency status the
u.s and so if we're seeing that trend
shift which uh a lot of people like this
is a very big picture idea but a lot of
people are um there's pretty big
implications for that and i think the
biggest the biggest losers of all of
this are the creditors the the
bondholders the people that own these
debt securities gotcha and one of the
other charts that you sent over was the
us 10-year secular trend that you you
had mapped out here
what are you seeing in this chart
yeah same same idea we don't have the
cpi numbers here but
essentially this you know i think rao
pal calls it the chart of truth a lot of
people kind of follow this and this is
mapping out a lot of things but debt and
demographics being being the biggest and
what's not shown here is that with every
kind of boom and bust cycle with every
credit cycle that we've seen about eight
to ten years uh give or take we come out
on the other side with far more debt at
the federal level at the household level
at the corporate level
aggregate debt to gdp globally and this
is somewhat of an estimate is around 400
so we just can't handle higher higher
yields even even if it's
deeply negative in real terms
adjusted after inflation in nominal
terms the financial system breaks at a
certain point whether that level's three
three and a half four uh we don't know
and and we'll see what we get to but
there's going to be a breaking point in
the bond market uh as these deals sort
just because of how over-indebted the
global economy is like this is this is
the macro picture right now
and when you say the
financial markets or the global economy
just breaks right at some point i assume
you're talking to some degree about the
bond market which you mentioned but what
is the what is the outcome for like the
average retail investor in this scenario
yeah so essentially when you talk about
the system breaking what you have in
this monetary system this economic
system
and why you kind of see these financial
crises occur right in 2008 yeah subprime
mortgages were bad but why did it tank
the global economy it's essentially
because you have fiat denominated assets
and liabilities and during bubbles
and during kind of credit expansions uh
you see the asset liability mismatch
everybody borrows investment assets and
the asset side of their balance sheet
goes up
and it's kind of self-reinforcing
everyone feels richer you reinvest
assets continue to go up and take on
more debt but when that trend reverses
and all of a sudden you have more
liabilities than ever
and because of rising yields because of
inflation because of just say you know a
global pandemic that that tank's
productivity what happens uh well the
earnings side of your balance sheet goes
down one person's earnings or one
person's spending is another person's
income and it's reinforcing on the
downside and all of a sudden now you
have a huge asset liability mismatch but
then the bad side and so what happens is
well you have an asset liability
mismatch you sell what you can to pay
down your liabilities and it's just a
cascading event where everything kind of
the house of cards falls down and so
we're not there yet i mean i'm not
calling for the end of the world
but this is why these credit you know
expansion and credit contractions this
is how they work um fiat money is
destroyed through debt debt uh default
or repayment and so when you have kind
of these mass default events these mass
insolvencies right now we're kind of in
the liquidity risk uh environment what
that eventually leads to uh if central
banks and governments don't kind of step
in and and help uh you know remonetize a
lot of this debt and inflate people's
balance sheets is what happens is that
that liquidity risk turns into solvency
risk and that's when kind of it turns
into actually systematic risk for the
fiat itself hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time